Oh,
the fine arts programs now in in I think
pretty much almost 100 percent are based
on contemporary art practices and so
very few universities,
very few programs teach technical skills
or teach you how to draw in a in a
classical way so they actually not
really teaching anything.
It's hard to know exactly what they're
doing,
I guess it was ever since the 19 sixties
through speeding this idea in the art
world that technical skills and ability
just aren't that important and that the
important thing is to find your,
I would say your political voice,
but it's very strange to me that this
has occurred because it seems to me that
before your voice is anything but a an
off color croak,
you have to become a disciple of a
discipline and an apprenticeship and and
learn the tools and trades of your craft
and learn how to be an artist because
there's a technical end to that.
I mean,
this is really almost an image of the
world as it stands now.
The,
the,
the purpose or the stated purpose of,
of,
of modern officially postmodern art was
to free the artists,
right to break,
to break away all the things that were
holding the artist back in terms of
rules and in terms of,
of uh,
just the way things were presented,
but when ended up happening is that
there were no more legitimate
legitimizing objective or you know,
strong legitimising structures around
the art.
The only thing left was politics and
relationships and status basically.
So our funders,
there's a big literature on creativity
and it's strongly,
which I know very well.
My lab designed the creative achievement
questionnaire which is used.
It's been used in hundreds of studies
now to assess lifetime creativity.
And so I've spent a lot of time looking
at the measurement of creativity and
also trying to understand creativity.
And the literature strongly suggest that
when you impose restrictions on people,
it actually makes them more creative
rather than less.
Because part of what creativity is the
overcoming of obstacles.
You know,
imagine someone who writes poetry and
the Haiku format.
Well,
it's,
it's very,
very restrictive and obviously
arbitrarily sold.
But the fact of the restriction is
partly what makes the poetic form
possible.
The same thing is true.
If you think about playing a game,
there's a.
there's far more things that you can't
do when you play chess than there are
things that you can do,
but there's still an infinite number of
variations of chess games.
So this idea that there's a dichotomy
between structure and rules and
creativity is,
is pernicious Lee false and contradicted
by the evidence.
And when you,
when you started to explore the art
world,
and the way it works is there's an irony
there that it purports to not have
boundaries on creativity and
instructions on care team,
but they're actually extremely strict
and they're hidden.
They're,
they're kind of this pernicious thing
underneath where we're actually you.
You have to present things in a very,
very precise way for it to be able to,
to enter into the legitimizing structure
of the,
of the gallery.